on a vu des gens recyclent et des objets
pour en faire des masques de protection
et bah là il ya un mec qui a réussi à
trouver double fonction au masque de
protection
regarde ces 18 et de la barca c'est
parti et à dégager trouvé la terre des
siècles d'âge est tombé comme ça et
c'est vrai c'est en vidant vendeur ma
tête si comme au vert tu fais ça tu fais
ça et puis vient d'inventer la triple
peine
attention avec valve comme ça si ça fait
des péchés capiteux un petit poussin
mais pas nous pas trop tout ça fait
cacher tu vois laval notre équipe a pris
corps au canada et je vous dis ya
beaucoup de gens qui ont du talent on en
a plein à regarder y en a qui pour
détendre l'atmosphère décide de mettre
le coronavirus en musique
regardez le marin qui a repris le fil de
gravure et e sont fort et j'embrasse
d'ailleurs les deux frérots ne revient
pas
regardez ça c'est énorme à bouazza merci
toi aussi un amour buzz ou pas bons ils
ont pas mis le ils ont pas mis le voilà
c'était voilà ça c'était le voisin le
bonjour voisin
mes joueurs ont regardé ça c'était
bonjour voisin mais regarder un seul
[ __ ] la parodie ne revient pas c'est
parti ici un petit peu voilà c'est ils
sont cueillis raquin au régime c'est
normal eh ben ils n'ont plus voilà les
chéris il y en a un autre qui voulait
faire connaissance avec son voisin ils
ont déjà l'air assez bien qu'on puisse
regarder ça
alors ça va arriver ah bah ils n'ont pas
non plus les chéris on a trouvé un
compte voilà bon avec les voisins c'est
là c'est la cata les chiffres et on a
aussi trouvé un candidat de la france a
un incroyable talent qui se sont
regardés un petit peu chez lui et il
nous propose de découvrir son nouveau
tour qu'il a fait avec son cul cul
regardez c'est assez bluffant regarder
ça
[Musique]
lui on va le voir dans incroyable talent
c'est sûr et certain lui mais il ya
quelque chose je te veux dans mon équipe
mes chéris vous connaissez philippe
croizon c'est un mec que je kiffe voilà
philippe croizon vous le savez vous
allez voir que lui aussi il a voulu
respecter les consignes de sécurité
faisait avant voilà philippe croizon
vous connaissez la pad bara philippe
donc regarder c'est parti mes amis en
ces moments difficiles j'ai décidé de
faire un petit tuto pour vous montrer
comment bien se laver les mains
et voilà je vous souhaite une bonne
journée à pertuis
mon philippot de sept gros bisous bauchi
bien dj aussi qui arrivent à être
irréprochable avec dj avec les jays
voilà c'est un dj donc avec lee jane
regardez c'est parti
[Musique]
bon en ce moment pour sortir un peu de
chez eux y en a aussi qui utilise à fond
les excuses de promener leur chien moi
je m'en rappelle à l'époque
franchement je m'étais pris un chien
juste pour aller promener le chien
essayer de faire des connaissances
alors en ce moment c'est vrai que quand
on veut sortir de chez soi un petit peu
on dit on va promener le chien même à sa
meuf tout ça pour faire un petit tour du
quartier pour respirer un peu les meufs
aussi à 10 à l'heure mais qu'ils verront
comme des chiens le premier chien il
s'est jamais autant promener que pendant
le coronavirus que pendant le
confinement alors regardez il ya un
chien qui veut sortir lui aussi est il
promène son chien
regardez il a bien pris l'attestation de
sortie ça c'est sûr et certain c'est
parti
[Musique]
bon alors là on voit ses deux chiens ils
sont bien ils sont tranquilles mais
aussi des chiens qui ont pas tous la
belle vie en ce moment parce que il ya
ceux qui sont dévalisés qui ont dévalisé
les rayons le pq voilà il y en a
certains qui se retrouvent à sec
regardez faut bien trouver une solution
pour les chiens c'est parti
[Musique]
bon il ya aussi un truc les chéris c'est
qu'en ce moment on peut pas faire de
sport donc il ya des gens qui ont trouvé
des solutions pour faire du sport chez
nous il ya un mec il a la chance d'avoir
un balcon regardez lui c'est un grand
marathonien c'est parti
ça va bien qu'il le confinement à la
foulée pactole
le parcours est moche déjà dehors c'est
vrai qu'on voit des vidéos des oufs en
ce moment au bout nous en envoyer plein
c'est un kiff il y en a d'autres qui
font leur sport de chez eux et on a vu
un mec qui en a profité pour faire une
bague à son colloque regarder
bon ça c'était bon s'il y en a plein qui
font du télétravail chez eux
et forcément il y en a qui sont avec les
enfants et pour travailler avec les
enfants c'est extrêmement compliqué donc
il ya un mec qui a trouvé un truc pour
esquiver son gosse pour esquiver ses
gosses regarde
[Applaudissements]
et c'est vrai que s on y glisse éric je
vois plein de gens craquer on adore être
avec les enfants etc
mais un moment c'est vrai qu'on a besoin
de se retrouver il n'y a pas que les
enfants les parents les professionnels
de la santé qui pète un câble pendant
cette période même les animaux commence
à péter un plomb
regardez
les chéris voilà donc aller elle est pas
bien elle est au bout de sa vie
forcément avec tout ce qui se passe en
ce moment aussi beaucoup de monde
beaucoup de personnes ont dû annuler
leurs vacances donc on leur fait des
gros bise on l'espère qu'on leur amène
un petit peu de soleil et pour pas
regretté maintenant qu'ils ont trouvé
des solutions regarder comment ce couple
se consolent franchement voilà c'est ça
c'est ça l'amour c'est ça la vraie vie
c'est comme ça qu'on a envie de vous
aimiez regarder
voilà il s'est fait c'est exceptionnel
franchement ils ont énormément de talent
je vois des trucs de fou